so tomorrow I'll be going away to Sri
Lanka I'm gonna be going to some
orphanages and helping some kids in need
and I thought instead of leaving you
guys sitting around wondering what's
going on I would do a little something
special for my 100th video this is a
quick story demonstrating how the worst
things in life can sometimes turn around
to become the best things this is a
photo that a friend took of me during
one of the best times of my life I was
in holiday in the United States and I
was playing a BB King signature lucile
guitar in Memphis Tennessee during this
trip I had so many amazing experiences
and met just the most incredible people
it was just an amazing time but here's
the quick story of how I almost got
killed and from that I got to have the
trip of a lifetime so that two years
back me and about six other mates were
just chillin you know doing what you
nice students do in a Friday night it
wasn't late maybe about eight o'clock
and we came across a group of about 20
guys and as we walked past they started
yelling some you know racial insults at
me and I thought to myself yeah maybe
they've just got a few screws loose or
something maybe they're just not all
there and we ignored them and we kept
walking then out of nowhere I hear these
footsteps running behind me I was like
well that's pretty weird it's probably
some kind of late-night jogger
but these footsteps are coming quick and
I was like man this guy really wants to
break the land speed record or something
but then this running guy hits me in the
back of the head with an object I have
no idea what was happening I was knocked
out for about a second or so and I hit
the deck and when I came around I
quickly set up and before I could even
say a word bang this guy kicked me
straight in the jaw the kick was so hard
that the blow broke my jaw at the hinge
the doctor said a kick any higher could
have ended me anyway when I went to the
hospital the doctors were like here make
just forget about your jaw it's not
gonna heal properly you're probably
gonna need surgery or something like
that and it looked like I would instead
of my job you know
closing vertically it was closing kind
of diagonally but hey every cloud has a
silver lining and this was mine
against all odds my jaw began to heal
correctly
and thank God for that because I would
have sounded pretty [ __ ] wallows
making voiceovers and the guy that
attacked me well he got caught and
sentenced to two years in prison and I
got awarded some damages from the court
hearing so after I graduated from
university I used some of that money to
go on a trip of a lifetime and now I
want to take you guys with me I've
documented it in such a way that it's
half a blog and half a documentary a
blog you mentoring it's quite
interesting guys but anyway I'd really
like for you to see it so just click on
it and come and enjoy the experience
with me and with that we shall resume
normal videos next week when I return as
usual don't forget to rate comment and
subscribe and I'll catch you guys later